die heute show am tag des großen erdogan
staatsbesuchs in deutschland das war der
ganz große bahnhof höchste
sicherheitsstufe was für ein aufwand für
einen türkischen präsidenten der uns
eigentlich nur besucht weil er pleite
ist ja es ist doch so entschuldigung
natürlich wir sollen ihm jetzt helfen
sein regime zu retten
die stimmung über den tag war insgesamt
eher frostig erdogan hat nicht ein
einziges mal irgendeine emotion gezeigt
wo wartet das stimmt nicht einmal als
sie diesen mann aus der pk abgeführt
haben moment da lächelt er
das ist sein humor
komisch die merkel gar nicht mit gelacht
umso besser die laune bei den in
deutschland lebenden erdogan fans dürfen
nicht vergessen die gibt es ja auch wir
haben ihn vermisst er hat ja viele jahre
lang hat er uns im ausland nicht
versucht also hier in deutschland man
kann nicht alles kritisch an einem
menschen sehen ein mensch muss auch
etwas gutes gemacht haben und das muss
man auch mal bewundern jeder möchte
ihnen sehen oder nicht wollen sie nicht
sehen nein wirklich nein ich konnte mir
nicht aussuchen
erdogan wünscht sich im verhältnis zu
deutschland zu uns neuerdings eine zitat
herzliche atmosphäre er ist halt doch
sensibel der mann da darf man sich von
den 70.000 menschen die in der türkei
ohne anklage im knast sitzen nicht
täuschen lassen
und ich überlege gerade weil man was
hatte denn die atmosphäre zwischen uns
und der türkei noch mal so vergiftet der
nationalsozialismus ist wieder
auferstanden
sie sind nachkommen der nazis das ist
nationalsozialismus sie sind faschisten
richtig wir sind ja faschisten abgehakt
jetzt ist wieder friede freude
eierkuchen
ja da kommt er warum in der
vergangenheit leben ist doch toll dass
uns der erde jetzt die hand reicht für
mich zeigt der man ehrliche reue hier
neuen sat 1
der recce hat ne ganze menge mist gebaut
früher das weiß er selber uns deutsche
hat er ja immer gerne als nazis oder
faschisten beschimpft
nur ja aber das tut ihm heute leid
[Applaus]
[Musik]
erdo sagt verzeih mir deutschland
wird seine ex angela ihm wirklich
nochmal eine allerletzte chance geben
wer wird sie das denn welche frau kann
einem mann schon lange böse sein der so
romantische sachen sagt verteidiger du
nazi jetzt in sat 1
[Musik]
ja
wolf als teil des fangs freikarten
nehme man wirklich jetzt frage ich sehr
nicht können diese haselnuss augen lügen
weil der damen und herren ich meine ja
denn erdogan der heuchelt doch der ist
doch nur so nett zu uns wegen seiner
wirtschaftskrise seit dem putsch haben
250.000 vor allem junge menschen die
türkei verlassen diesen check die dia
braucht die türkische lira hat
dramatisch an wert verloren höchste
inflation seit 2003 und dann hat ihm
auch noch trump den wirtschaftskrieg
erklärt aber die türken wären sich holt
eure dollar unter der matratze vor hatte
präsident erdogan gefordert und tauscht
sie um sie verbrennen dollar oder
verarbeiten die geldnoten zu hackfleisch
ich muss sagen ich möchte keinen
unterschied ist ja sonst auch kaum
fleisch drin
das wird den abend ist aber eine lehre
sein wenn die türken ihr eigenes geld
zerstückeln und morgen eröffnet erdogan
dann feierlich das wissen sie die große
ditib moschee in köln ja das wird super
das wird super ja der islam verband
ditib ist ja als propaganda truppe
erdogan als politischer arm in
deutschland hat hier immer wieder seine
gegner ausspioniert und zwar auf befehl
von ganz oben wo auch immer unser volk
ist wenn einer mit bekommt oder davon
erfährt dass sich jemand falsch benimmt
oder ähnliches soll er unsere
sicherheitskräfte benachrichtigen
das hilft uns sehr das erleichtert uns
die arbeit ja das macht wirklich für
alle einfacher müssen wir die nur noch
abholen und feiern
das dürfen wir nicht hinnehmen ganz
ernsthaft dass deutsch türken hier bei
uns in angst leben nur weil sie ein
problem mit erdogan haben und ich wette
viele kinder fragen sich jetzt zu hause
warum sind wir denn dann wieder so nett
zu den bösen bann
serdar somuncu versucht mal dass kurz
kindgerecht zu erklären
[Musik]
hallo kinder manchmal muss man so tun
als ob man jemanden mag den man
eigentlich voll doof findet klingt
komisch ist aber so eure mama und papa
zum beispiel lassen sich auch aber eine
scheidung wäre zu teuer deshalb bleiben
die beiden zusammen sprechen sie ruhig
mal darauf an oder der oli hier totaler
vollidiot besucht mich ständig an meinem
bauwagen und bringt mettbrötchen mit
weil er schon wieder vergessen hat dass
ich kein schwein es ist egal
und ganz wichtig kinder erdogan ist
nicht gleich türkei die deutsche und die
türkische kultur sind total verflochten
wir haben mehrere weltkriege zusammen
verloren jedes jahr fliegen deutsche
abiturienten in die türkei um von
gepanschten bacardi blind zu werten
entwirft man doch nicht einfach so weg
und deswegen helfen den türken ein
trottel
weil die gute kunden sind die
importieren jedes jahr deutsche waren
für 22 milliarden
siemens und die deutsche bahn bauen bald
ein neues schienennetz in der türkei ein
modernes schnell schienennetz dann sind
türkische journalisten zwei stunden
früher im knast wenn die deutsche bahn
weiß wie man schnell schienennetz baut
das ist doch gar nicht der punkt was ich
den kindern sagen wie wir deutschen
müssen jetzt halt mal ein wochenende so
tun als wäre der job ein dufter typ
gefühle vortäuschen hier
ich zeige euch das mal den oliver hasse
ich wirklich nie die pest aber es ist
absolut kein problem für mich für die
kamera so zu tun als wäre mein bester
freund
der fette nazi
komm mal her na los komm juli
[Applaus]
[Musik]